[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Shannon.
I'm going to talk to you about
how to draw fast on mobile GPUs
with Vulcan.
So what do I mean by mobile?
Most of the time when people
say mobile GPU, what they really
mean is a tile-based GPU.
Not all mobile GPUs are
tile-based, but most are.
This means that the render
target is split into separately
rendered tiles, so the GPU
can keep the resources needed
to render a single tile stored
in on-chip memory, which
is fast and inexpensive
power-wise to access.
The flip side of this is that
bandwidth for reading off-chip
is limited.
So if you're familiar
with desktop rendering,
you may know more about
immediate renders.
Those work in a fairly
straightforward manner.
You describe your scene
as a series of draw calls,
draw me triangle 1,
2, 3, and the GPU
receives these draw
calls and executes them
as they're received,
committing each one out
to the framebuffer.
So your scene builds up
one draw all at a time.
On the flip side,
tiling renderers
are a little more complicated.
You still describe your scene
as a series of draw calls,
but the GPU, rather
than executing them when
it receives them, bins them.
This means that it's
keeping track of which draw
calls affect which tiles.
When you finished
describing your scene,
then it executes the
list of draw calls
affecting a single tile and
then commits the results
to the framebuffer before
moving on to another tile,
so your scene builds
up one tile at a time.
This gets interesting when it
intersects with multiple paths
rendering techniques.
These are used for
a lot of things,
one of the most obvious being
post-processing effects.
There's stuff like tone
mapping, exposure control,
and HDR that essentially
act as color filters.
You render your
scene in one pass,
and then in a subsequent pass,
you apply a filter to it,
using one pixel from
the previous pass
to determine the output
for the current pass.
There are also
post-processing effects
which use multiple pixels.
They need information
about neighboring pixels
to determine the current
pixel of the subsequent pass,
like blur, bloom,
and focus control.
There's also deferred
shading, where
you're rendering a lot of
material data out into buffers
and then using that to render
your scene in another pass.
And this has been
particularly painful
for mobile devices because
of that bandwidth and memory
pressure.
There's also volumetric
effects, where
you may want to accumulate
things like participating media
across multiple passes.
So what this looks like
on a tiling render,
without the Vulcan
multi-pass mechanism,
is that for each pass, you
have to render each tile
and commit the results
to the framebuffer.
Then later passes
must reload that data,
loading back from that
expensive off-chip memory.
Multi-sampling, MSAA,
multiplies this off-chip cost.
Because rather than
a single pixel,
you were having to
commit multiple samples
to off-chip memory.
This adds up incredibly quickly.
So Vulcan adds the multi-pass
mechanism directly to the API.
This allows you to describe
all of those passes
as a series of sub-passes.
That means that
for each tile, you
can render all of the
sub-passes before moving on
to the next tile.
This allows relevant
data to stay on chip.
And, as an added bonus, you
can resolve multi-sample
after the last sub-pass and
store only the single pixel
resolved result.
So there are some tips
for using this well.
First, you want to make
sure that the attachments
to your framebuffer have the
load-and-store disposition set
correctly.
Basically, you don't want to use
load-op-load or store-op-store,
unless you actually
need to load or store.
Otherwise you're paying
overhead that you don't need to.
And you can use transient
attachment for data
that you never store, like
the traditional use of a depth
buffer, in order to avoid
allocating any off-chip memory
to store them.
Also, you want to set your
dependencies when using
this mechanism as by region.
Otherwise, by default, they're
considered to be global,
and you have to wait for all of
the pixels of the previous pass
to complete before
beginning your current pass.
That defeats the purpose.
And, for now, if you're
using this mechanism,
you can only benefit
if your sub-pass
needs to access a single
pixel from the prior pass.
Otherwise it's not by region.
So blur and bloom
can't benefit yet.
There's is room for this
to change in the API
in the future.
The upside is this is efficient.
Tiling renderers can save
clock cycles and power
by avoiding those off-chip
read/writes, which
opens the door for rendering
techniques that were previously
thought too costly
on mobile devices.
But mobile devices aren't
the only ones that benefit.
Immediate renderers
can still do things
like avoid allocating
memory outside of a cache
for transient attachments.
So armed with this knowledge,
I hope you get out there
and you draw things fast.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]